Good evening.
I trust you had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, but I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Tassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Tassa
So we are continuing with this discourse, number 44, called the shortest series of questions and answers.
we've been through the section concerning sakaya ditti or the identity personhood personality well person view eightfold path concentration and the sankara the volitional formations and all that so now the next section really we don't have to go through in detail it's called the cessation of feeling and perception
And it's a specific experience that comes after somebody has attained all the jhanas.
So there are four, what we call rupa jhanas or jhanas that depend upon some object such as a metta or the breath.
And then there are the arupa jhanas, which are not dependent on that, but have the same quality, the same mental quality of perfect equanimity
that one comes to in the fourth jhana, the fourth absorption.
And there are four of those arupa jhanas, the jhanas which don't have an actual specific object.
Now, if you happen to be a non-returner, which is the third level of attainment, right, to the first stream entrant, then there is the once-returner, he only has to come back once, and there is a non-returner.
So that's somebody who has
lost any delight in the sensual world but still delights in these jhana worlds these absorption worlds and then finally of course full liberation with the arahat now this particular experience so the cessation of feeling of perception can only be had to the top two right you could have to be a non-returner or an arahat in order to um in order to experience this so therefore
If you are at that level, then you can read the page.
But what we're interested in is really that such a level exists.
Now, that point where perception and feeling come to an end is for some people an experience of nirvana, and for other writers, no, it's not.
Now, the funny thing is that you can experience nirvana
in the lower attainments in fact the first attainment is an experience of nibbana even if only as the buddha says like a flash of lightning but you see everything as it were everything to be seen is seen but darkly and uh and therefore it would seem that it doesn't quite equate with uh nibbana but some people say it does the extinction of feeling and perception and um
according to damadina you can't actually make a decision to do it it occurs to it does not occur to him i shall attain cessation of perception and feeling or i am attaining perception of cessation of perception of feeling nor afterwards i have attained uh it just it just comes when the time is right
And it's done, as I say, through this process of the jhana.
Now, the interesting thing is, is that when a person comes out of that state, the three characteristics of existence are available to them.
So the first one is the voidness contact.
The voidness is the first thing they are aware of.
which is, of course, the not-self.
Remember that word sunya, emptiness, which the Mahayana turned into a generalized concept of insubstantiality.
Here, in the Theravada tradition, it's more to do with the emptiness of self.
Then there's the signless contact, which is a funny way of saying that you see that everything is arising and passing away.
Actually, what you see are consciousnesses arising and passing away.
Remember, we can never experience the world out there as it is.
When you're looking at a tree, you're not experiencing the tree as it is.
You're experiencing the tree as your eyes will allow you to experience it.
And then there's dukkha, of course, the desireless contact, which is the end of suffering.
So that's this whole section here.
on the cessation of perception and feeling.
And it's just good to know that there are such very high-level states.
The whole experience in Nirvana is, shall we say, debated, which may come as a surprise to you.
There are those schools that say it's like a blackout, almost like a very deep, deep, deep sleep.
There's a disappearance, you might say.
And this is definitely understood by those
say in the Mahasi, connected to the Mahasi tradition, whereas those who come from the Ajahn Mun tradition, Ajahn Mahabua, Ajahn Chah, they would express it as pure awareness.
The same seeming contradiction exists in Mahayana, where the Madhyamika people who follow Nagarjuna would talk about it as a blackout, as a state of deep unknowing.
and the Yogacara people would see it as pure awareness.
So people struggle with that.
And one or two writers have tried to explain how that is.
But basically that there seems to be these two types of experience, which are both non suffering.
And that's the important thing is non suffering.
So we can leave that for another day,
another another time so we can go on now to feeling uh so again uh uh visaka who remember was uh well those still remains uh the husband of damadina he asks how many kinds of feeling are there so so i'll give you a moment there to answer that how many kinds of feeling are there it's another test
So there are three, are there not?
Painful, pleasant, and neither painful nor pleasant.
Now, what is a pleasant feeling?
What is a painful feeling?
What is a neither painful nor pleasant feeling?
So whatever bodily or mental, whatever is felt bodily or mentally, right?
So the body and the heart, right?
The heart feeling as pleasant and soothing is pleasant feeling.
And whatever is felt as
Bodily or heart ways, mentally painful and hurting is painful feeling.
And whatever felt bodily or mentally is neither soothing nor hurting, that is neither pleasant nor unpleasant feeling.
Now lady, what is pleasant and what is painful in regard to pleasant feeling?
Okay, so what is pleasant and what is unpleasant in regard to pleasant feeling?
So what is what is painful and what is pleasant in regard to painful feeling and what is pleasant and what is painful in regard to neither painful nor pleasant feeling.
Right.
So we take it easy.
So pleasant feeling is pleasant when it persists, painful when it changes.
Right now here, I think there's some we have to understand this as
our reaction to pleasant and unpleasant.
As a pleasant feeling fades away, then a pleasant feeling is just fading away.
But because we might be attached to that pleasant feeling, then there is a feeling of loss, and that's where the painfulness comes in.
Or you could see it simply that as the pleasant feeling fades away, it's losing its pleasantness, and in that sense, it's becoming unpleasant.
And so it's the same with painful feelings.
When it persists, it's painful, but as it changes, it becomes pleasant.
So one can understand that if you've got a pain and the pain slowly is fading away, it is experienced as something pleasant, nor pleasant feeling is pleasant when there is knowledge of it.
So when you're aware of neutral feelings, they're not painful, they're not unpleasant, they're just generally okay.
and painful when you have no knowledge of it.
So that's a bit of a conundrum.
I've not been able to find why it's painful when you have no knowledge of it.
What I suggest is that when the feeling arises with the perception,
If there is a feeling and there's no perception, then there's an underlying ignorance to it.
And that when it's recognized is painful.
But frankly, I've emailed somebody to find out if they understand that last sentence.
So this is something that we can actually be aware of in our meditation.
So there's a lovely, pleasant emotion.
And as it passes away, it's losing its pleasantness.
And in that sense, it's becoming unpleasant.
When we have a painful feeling, such as a physical one, say pain in the knee, and it's slowly disappearing and we see it disappear, we can see that that loss of pain is experienced as something which is pleasant.
On top of that, of course, is our reaction.
which we've, during this time anyway, put to one side.
So your reaction to pleasantness, of course, is to grasp it, to want to develop it.
And as it fades away, of course, then you start getting worried and anxious.
And that's another type of suffering.
And if it's painful and you're aversion to it, then the aversion itself is a state of suffering.
So remember, there's pleasant feeling and unpleasant feeling.
both physical and mental, which are quite natural.
The Buddha has them too, but our reactions are unnecessary.
So the next section is to do with underlying tendencies.
Now these underlying tendencies, they sit, shall we say, beneath our consciousness, beneath what's known as the mental continuum.
And
When something actually comes in which drops down, as it were, and excites the tendencies that are underneath that level of consciousness, then of course they pop up.
So very simply, you walk into the kitchen and you can see the tea urn and immediately you think, I'll have a cup of tea.
you might have thought that before you enter the kitchen but on seeing something it's something will arise an underlying tendency will manifest so uh what underlying tendencies underlies pleasant feeling what what underlying tendency underlies pleasant feeling and what for painful feeling and for neither pleasant or unpleasant so i'll let you guess the underlying tendency
to something that's pleasant is, is of course, excitement.
Because that's how we feel when something pleasant comes up, we want to grasp it.
And that's your, that's your tanha, that's your wrong desire.
Now, this word is often translated as lust.
But lust, of course, is normally understood to be a sexual thing.
But the word raga, which is trying to translate is excitement, excitement,
even uncontrolled passion for something.
Now, that word excitement rings true for me in a consumerist society because the whole point of consumerism is to make you constantly feel excited with the new, you know, a new mobile phone, a new fashion.
See, it's everything that's got to be new and that new has to come up just just before the previous new is beginning.
Just after, shall we say, the previous new is beginning to die out because then, of course, boredom arises and you wouldn't buy it.
So you've always got to have something new and that's to create that sort of bubbly excitement.
The underlying tendency to aversion
is of course underlined sorry for painful feeling of course the underlying tendency is aversion you don't want it so there again is your tanha that's your wrong desire and the underlying tendency underneath painful and unpaid is of course ignorance just it's ignorance again is is a slightly wrong word because it's not that you're culpable you're just not aware of it
So the underlying tendency is to be unaware of it.
So once we become more sensitive to the body, for instance, we become aware of small sensations that arise.
You're more in contact, you're more embodied, you might say.
It's the same with emotions.
You might not have felt emotions actually in the body.
Some people don't.
But eventually through meditation, you actually start contacting emotions in the body.
you can feel also fine mental states within the body so that's an opening up to the more finer feelings that we can experience now the next question is does the underlying tendency of excitement underlie pleasant feeling all pleasant feeling
Does the underlying tendency of aversion underlie all painful feeling?
And does the underlying tendency of ignorance underlie all, neither painful nor pleasant feelings?
And the answer, of course, is no.
The underlying tendency doesn't always there.
So sometimes, especially if we're practicing well, a pleasant feeling will come up without that desire for excitement, for holding on to it,
sometimes when unpleasant mental states comes up we can be quite equanimous with them so it's not necessary for these things to come up and of course ignorance doesn't have to be there you can make yourself sensitive to your sensations your feelings your emotions and moods so then the next question is what should be abandoned in regard to pleasant feelings unpleasant feelings painful feelings and
neither pleasant nor unpleasant feelings so of course what should be abandoned is that very excitement that very aversion and that very ignorance so that's pretty straightforward we should abandon that in fact that's the uh second the first noble the second noble truth is where the buddha states that that tanha is the cause this wrong desire is a cause of all our suffering and and our purpose is to abandon it
So let go of it.
Friend Visakha, the underlying tendency to lust does not have to be abandoned in regard to all pleasant feeling.
Oh, sorry.
Then he asks, does this have to be abandoned to all pleasant feeling?
And of course, it doesn't have to be abandoned to all pleasant feeling because, well, we've just said it, so I'm getting confused.
Okay, Visakha, now what she says,
that these pleasant feelings don't have to be abandoned.
Sorry, the underlying lust does not have to be abandoned by way of these jhana states, these absorption states.
So when you enter into absorption, into an absorption state, then of course these pleasant, unpleasant feelings, they all get pushed down, they all get suppressed.
And
And then finally when somebody enters and abides in those places and touches upon Nibbāna, then there's a longing to continue that practice and work towards it.
Now the interesting thing is that with
With that, he abandons ignorance and the underlying tendency to ignorance does not underlie that.
Now that's interesting in this sense that ignorance is one of the last fetters that hold you to this existence.
And of course, you can't abandon ignorance itself.
You can't abandon not knowing.
What you can abandon is the product of not knowing.
which is the sense of self, which is conceit.
So with the ending of that sense of self and the conceit of self, the ignorance, of course, disappears.
So that's a bit more subtle, you might say.
Okay.
And the final part is counterpart.
what is the counterpart of pleasant feeling so painful feeling is the counterpart right so right okay what's the counterpart of painful feeling well it's pleasant feeling is the counterpart what is the counterpart of neither pleasant or unpleasant feeling in this sense now is ignorance which is the counterpart right so that's what is on the other side what is the counterpart of ignorance
true knowledge is the counterpart of ignorance so in other words seeing things as they really are is under is going to undermine ignorance what is the counterpart of true knowledge deliverance is the counterpart of true knowledge so in other words you have to be uh you have to move towards deliverance uh or should we say the the the um the true knowledge leads you to deliverance um
This word patibhaga, which is being translated here, both means opposition, but also means supplementary.
So here we're sort of coming the other way.
Because of true ignorance, we're moving into deliverance.
And the counterpart of deliverance, of course, is nirvana.
Then he asks, lady, what is the counterpart to nirvana?
Friend Visakha, you have pushed this line of questioning too far.
were not able to grasp the limit to questions all right so there's there's a limit to what questions can get you to for the holy life friend visaka merges in nibbana culminates in nibbana ends in nibbana if you wish friends visaka go to the blessed one and ask him about the meaning of this as the blessed one explains it to you so you should remember it so questions can only take you so far
After that, you've got to start practicing.
But remember that Visakha is already a non-returner and really he's coming along to see how his ex-wife understands the Dharma now that she's a full Arahant.
Now, the next bit, of course, is interesting because this shows a relationship which would have been very, very strange, I think, for those times.
Then the lay follower of Hisakha, having delighted and rejoiced in the Bhikkhuni Dhammadina's words, rose from his seat, and after paying homage to her, keeping her on his right, he went to see the Blessed One."
So that a man should behave like that towards a woman must have been, especially if there was an audience there, must have been, shall we say, interesting.
And then he goes to the Blessed One and, of course,
gives the whole entire conversation that he's had to to the buddha and the buddha replies the bhikkhuni damadina is wise visakha bhikkhuni damadina has great wisdom if you had asked me the meaning of this i would have explained it to you in the same way that bhikkhuni damadina has explained it such is its meaning and so you should remember it and that was what the blessed one said
And the lay follower, Visakha, who was a lay person at the third level of attainment, was satisfied and delighted in the Blessed One's words.
So there we have this wonderful discourse of questions and answers for the Dikuni Damodina, who was a fully liberated being.
So I hope you found that inspirational and that it will in fact fire you
to continue your practice and attain full liberation from all suffering sooner rather than later.
So we can sit for a little while.